One of the most difficult skills to improve
through real-life situations is listening.
But have no fear – you can target your learning
to make it a breeze!
Here are four ways to make this happen.
If you know you're going into a situation
where English is spoken, you can prepare yourself
by brushing up on the likely words which could
be used.
For example, if you're going to the airport,
you're most likely to hear things about your
flight, destination, visa and luggage.
Before you go to the airport, you can review
the vocabulary related to these topics.
Don’t forget, if you don’t catch everything
the first time, it's okay to ask them to repeat
it for you, which is also good practice.
You can also practise by listening for specific
information.
If we go back to the airport example, you
could listen out for your destination or flight
number.
This will keep the learning focused and practical
for you.
Like with reading, you can choose what you
want to listen to for practice.
If you're a TV or film fan, try watching a
section without subtitles and then watch again
with subtitles to check your understanding.
You can also listen to radio programmes or
podcasts from all over the world.
Choose a topic you're interested in and you’ll
be amazed how many interesting programmes
are available!
It may be hard to believe, but watching people
can also help you listen.
How does this work?
When people talk, they normally use more than
just their words to communicate.
They're conveying meaning with their tone
of voice, hand gestures, the way they sit
or stand, and so on.
Carefully observe the people you listen to.
Linking it all together can help make the
meaning clear to you.
One thing to be aware of here is that there
may be cultural differences in body language.
If you are visiting somewhere new, it’s
a good idea to have a quick read about the
customs and culture of the place beforehand.